carmelo anthony joining us here in
studio did you walk here you don't live
too far from here
no I didn't walk I didn't walk today
usually I were to walk but not today
have you ever worn a disguise in New
York just a hoodie hoodie some glasses I
had what do you hear though when you
walk down the street New York oh that's
not him oh man you look you look like
mellow oh yeah yeah get that always got
a lot yeah but do people give you advice
do they criticize you compliment you
it's like uh who's the next head coach
yeah you get all of that you get all of
those questions and then you have some
guys who feel like they're 2gm some guys
feel like they're two-owner some guys
feel like they should be your point
guard or they should be your Center or
everybody has the crazy opinion up in
New York but did you ever play West 4th
Street
yes growing up growing up I couldn't get
in a game they wouldn't let me in I died
why is that
mellow I don't know you you had to have
connects I know but guys who were
dribbling losing and like it's point and
he's dribbling saying I got next and
he's just lost the game that's not fair
I waited two hours gotta earn your
stripes what if we if we went down there
as five we're getting we're getting a
game right Oh without a doubt without a
doubt how would we do on West 4th with
you I mean look at my guys here Oh we'll
be all right we uh we would we'd be all
right what if you're not allowed to
shoot
we wouldn't you okay
McLovin I don't think you've seen us
shoot I think he's seen enough well
lunch lunch time you just walked by and
played a pickup game
ah last offseason that's all so you just
you were going there just walking by and
just decided to say it wasn't it was
outdoors all cash outdoors I was just
walking I heard I was out and about
Ashley and I heard some ID I was playing
he said oh they they got runs over here
and I went in a tow watching my
competitive spirit kicked in no no and
then I just started playing but those
are the times where I have the most fun
we're playing the game
it's nothing playing you just go you
just have pickup games you have fun with
it and that's it but somebody wants to
check you yeah everybody of course like
they they can shut you down yeah of
course always that guy as always that
guy always that guy but I try to play
with guys who have some type of talent
on the basketball court no then you
don't want to play with how how
addictive is scoring scoring is very
addictive especially when you know you
can do it and you just eat a do you eat
at it and you feel like nothing can
really stop you can never get too many
points you can never get too vertical
like even when you're scoring 60 you can
never get too many you can never get to
me but I I I try to tell people when you
see great scores like they're so hungry
like they just keep like Iverson just
kept coming after you Kobe keeps coming
after you well it's a it's a mentality
that that you have to have and you know
some people have it and some people
don't most points you ever score any
level
I like 70-something when I was it was
like summer league something like that's
not that's not that Rucker League stuff
where guys will put up big numbers is it
I mean it was it was like a program back
in Baltimore I had him at my rec center
and all the pros came out of it it was
just one of those days in the summertime
when did you know you were good oh I
always believed that I was good growing
up but it wasn't until I started
matching up with you know some of the
top guys I was either in my class or he
there in the country and I okay I can I
can I can hold my own against these guys
and my confidence just started growing
from there but who's the player were you
it wasn't it wasn't one particular
player you know it was playing against
teams playing against top teams that was
on the mind on the circuit
you know those teams always had highly
rated guys though
like you know I want that challenge I
want that matchup you know hopefully I
can get it
carmelo anthony joining us here in the
man cave first time you saw LeBron we
first time I saw LeBron was uh in New
Jersey right before we was about to play
them and in high school and we was
actually we walked in a hotel together
and that's what that was the first time
that we actually met can you be friends
right away or is that competition it was
it was more of a respect factor um you
know knowing what he was doing in his
school and in high school no why was
that in high school I was about to go to
college he's one year uh uh below me
he'd also be it became a mutual respect
at first and then it led to the you know
the competition I know you win a
national title at Syracuse but if you
could have come out of high school right
to the pros which you've done that no
you weren't ready oh I don't think I was
I was ready I don't think I was I had an
opportunity to come but I just always
wanted to go to always wanted to go to
college but that moment oh when you win
a national title you sort of
accomplished everything basketball was
right I was having so much fun though at
school like I was just having so much
fun it was so much excitement you know
being up there Sanford youth at that
time Sarah choose was maybe the number
one party school in America you didn't
get cheated up there no they got it so I
was actually enjoy I was enjoying myself
up there Sarah too so I didn't want to
leave and didn't Bay hum bore me into
office they kind of kicked me out he
said you gotta go you yeah he said is
your time your service is no longer
media do you remember what you said at
the ESPYs that year after you won the
national title yeah well I want to thank
myself you you know you get out you get
up in those situations in this you know
you want you want to thank everybody
else you know sometimes you forget about
all the people that you want to thing
but you people never thanked themselves
now she's putting in the work and going
through all of that so nobody you know I
was there sometimes you got to pat
yourself on the back
yeah cuz maybe nobody else is going to
exactly um could you play differently if
I said could you play like LeBron does
no you just told it to different type
again like you're not wired that way
or you don't have that talent no no I
know I think I mean the tables that
LeBron has yeah yeah I think it's more
of style of play than anything I think
for me my game is uh kind of you know
it's a it's a attack mode at all at own
moments
it's kill to be killed it's you know
tackle be tech be attack then you know
in the Brawn situation he has so many
different facets of the game use his
physical strength his his passion is
more training to me than his scoring is
you know you know so for him is more of
a pass first I pass first name because
that's what you know he grew up on and
that's the type of player he was
and then scoring just came and gig it
comes natural tone for me it was more it
was the opposite and I was always taught
to you know apply pressure put the ball
in the hole that way I was taught that
from day one but you weren't a tall kid
growing up so you learn well I learned
the skills of the actual skills of the
game when I was you know junior let me
fresh me in high school I was only 6 6-1
6-2 I was playing I was playing point
guard I went you know I was playing the
guard position so who was your idol back
then I was all I'm a Bernard King fan
but even as a point guard as a point
guard it was you know it was of course
it was magic you know of course watching
them but I grew up in an era of you know
when I can remember the game you know it
was Stephon Marbury you know it was in
high school coming out Allen Iverson you
know was there Ray Allen
you know the dozers the guys that
actually grew up on Lamar Odom you know
he was actually one of my favorite high
school players to ever watch the you
know ever watch so these are guys that I
looked up to when I was young and coming
up you everybody's got a Jordan story
everybody have a Michael Jordan story
which one join has a lot of stories no
do you like first time you faced him or
like it I'll never play I never played
against MJ I came to you after he
with us yeah I came here after he
retired yeah so you don't have a Michael
Jordan story not on the court what do
you got off the court
oh I don't that'll put that over here no
just you oh just there's a little truth
in every bit of kid oh not this not this
he's my boss man he's my boss
yeah it is his his image just literally
hangs over the NBA I mean it's amazing
to be retired for this amount of time
it's like Babe Ruth with baseball yeah
Michael is still there guys
still wearing his gear he's as popular
as he was if not more than when he was
play well I think it's that it's the
relevancy of kind of the culture and
what he you know his impact that he made
on the coach that he put on the culture
from us from the sneaker game to just
the way that he changed the game the
style of the game the style that you
played the game I think people you know
still recognize that in kids the more
like they only tablished that they on
their phones you know they're just going
back and looking at old footage and you
know taking that in and now you know the
kids now can we respond to respect that
you grew up in Baltimore
were you a are you Ravens fan I'm a
Ravens fan I'm a or do you like the
Redskins I'm a Ravens no I'm a Ravens
fan for sure who's through I wish I have
a Ravens tattoo him on I had since I was
when did you get there I was 16 15 6 ok
that one your first one one of them so
you come home how's that how's that go
over my mom didn't see it you kept long
sweet yeah yeah um I say I just say you
know I pull my weight down okay this is
not for kids all right
I would come home and I would just
always have something around shirt on or
something the way she found out was it
was a I had a high school basketball
game and it was a big game too and they
had my picture in the sports section not
the paper and the shot that I was taking
was a layup it's on your right hand to
some Rygaard there so she saw it and she
tried to rip my arm off kind of rip the
tattoo off but realized that it was
permanent could you teach if I gave you
an hour to teach the triangle
you know could you teach it I can teach
the basic concept of facts with triangle
is it overrated I don't think I don't
think it's overrated it's just like in
today's game though
given what Golden State is doing see
they doughnuts that you can't it's hard
to compare anything to what going the
state is going I love how people say
it's a system but you if that system
includes every right yeah I mean it is
hard to try to compare to what they're
doing out there I mean it changes the
style of the style of playing basketball
and everybody is trying to implement
what they're trying to do is he the best
player in the game oh I mean that's
that's a very difficult if I said you
can start your team with anybody in the
NBA right now um I don't know man and I
love Steph Curry I love his game I love
everything about him but it's just hard
to kind of narrow things down I won't be
putting up position where I have to
narrow I'll give you two four or five
guys down and I can't do that you
wouldn't take okay see to me it'd be
like I'd start my team I'd have no
problem with Steph Curry I have no
problem with stuff but I'm trying to
think who would be that guy you would
put there and right now that position no
right now starting your team cuz LeBron
at his age Anthony Davis is great I
still put the put LeBron there ya know
cuz Steph a couple years ago created
headlines when I said are you the best
scorer in the league are you better than
LeBron he goes yeah and everybody's like
what did you hear what Steph just said
well he way not I mean as an athlete as
a competitor you're not going to say no
are you better score than LeBron I
believe so are you better score than
Steph Curry
I believe okay yeah see that's just best
that's my you have to have that mindset
I always have them I said I don't think
you know when it comes to being on that
court I don't think anybody is better
because that's my mindset are you gonna
be involved in who's the next coach I
hope so
have you been I'll talk to you about
this not yet not yet I mean we've talked
briefly but you know not yet will you
retire as a Knick that's my goal how
long is your contract for I have another
couple years and then
hopefully that's not another contractor
I know you got a busy day you're gonna
be at Grand Central today
yeah that's we were gonna have a good
time at Grand Central explain what
you're doing there all right so I teamed
up with with Gillette um you know the
clinical clear gel the deodorant so the
whole object of this activation at Grand
Central is well I'm gonna get a bunch of
guys men you know everybody deal with
pressures differently you know so we're
gonna set them up with a polygraph test
and we're gonna ask them tough tough
questions that's gonna get them worked
up and just see how they handle a weight
are you getting personal like like you
know you cheat on your wife or stuff no
no no that's not us
no that's too that's too personal okay
I'm suggesting that's like that that's
to a person okay
did you use the phone on the owner why
you using a bathroom thing phase of
things of death do you want them to be
nervous I want them to I want them to
sweat to see how they feel under
pressure and then once you get you once
you get that spike up you know I want to
I want you to see how you react under
pressure and you know with the with the
with the deodorant and what the gel is
so are they works are they gonna say we
go sit we go see if it works okay so you
know flying deodorant and then you hook
them up to the polygraph we might we
might let them you know put this to put
the gel on them and then we don't give
them the test if you wanted to make me
nervous what would you ask me I don't
know I will have to do my research on
homework I don't have to do my homework
I don't like coming to the table without
my without my facts how would I do in a
shooting contest 15 to 18 feet against
you
yeah I'll she backs in you die
I do well okay I mean I'm not afraid I
said I should be asking you that
yeah yeah yeah see now with the
polygraph test you sit there and it just
go crazy on wrong no you know just
flatline okay we go that dude was cool
but then you cool under prop I'm cool
under pressure
that's what matters like you have to
have that mindset got you you have to
stay mellow but I don't I don't need
deodorant deodorant needs me that's how
cool I am
well you you need you need this Gillette
you you need this one
would you see would you lower yourself
and do a shooting contest with me
how are you from the line I'm 80 some
percent yeah yeah so am i okay I don't
know I haven't seen it no it's good it's
not documented it's good pure
yeah okay my nickname is pure so but
he's got a work where they work with you
no no no no they see it every day I got
it I got a basketball hoop in the man
cave my nickname was Clinic cuz I put on
a clinic so okay yeah all right I
thought it was clinical gel hey great
see you thank you for coming by thanks
for having luck with a triangle with
your new coach whoever that's gonna be
yes and it'll just keep in mind I'm
ready to have me back that a no she was
such as soon gay yeah absolutely
all right I'll shoot for money I like
that ice Carmelo Anthony you can see him
at Grand Central Terminal that'll be
today do you know what time you're gonna
be there I'll be there round uh maybe
tooless Jewish Jewish Jewish you can see
him stop by a degree with a Gillette
clinical clear gel you can go now no you
can go now at the doors open now okay
and then you're gonna moderate you're
gonna be asking these guys tough
questions yes thank you for coming by
thanks for having irony's Carmelo
Anthony a second best shooter in the
room here can I just say that the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience